hello and welcome to this video yes this
is a kind of a new experience for me
because I'm recording this video out of
my new home yes my has finished and i'm
back online that's really cool this is
going to be uploaded basically right
after it is recorded together with two
videos i still had yeah in my in my um
my hard drive that had recorded before
my move but this is the third one to
make it a complete trio let's say the
home videos for sunday the twenty-eighth
yeah okay yeah please give me feedback I
hope it works alright and down from
technical point of view let's see 95
here by my way hmm an interesting line
here c4 is hanging and there's even c5 i
guess to give them to give a pawn here
for compensation I think I'll go for
that it's an interesting idea I will
have some quite serious compensation on
the dark squares he has to take i guess
and i would like to go like efore and
Bishop e3 e4 that's nigera still I think
that it's not to be feared I want to go
Bishop e3 but should be two castles just
to develop quickly when I head looks
okay it looks okay for white I should
have quite substantial confer
compensation for the pawn here his dark
squares up quite a problem and he cannot
easily play t5 now for Bishop e3 because
of visual
94 I just play Quincy too I guess and
the Knights will have to yeah we'll be
pushed back now so I'm happy with this
position yeah please also give me
feedback further about the sound it's a
different acoustics I guess in this room
I have no idea but it's better was or
anything can I tell you and I have a
different microphone position and so on
maybe there are some things to that will
kind of evolved over time and be
improved upon but maybe it is already
good i have already have no idea so if i
go Bishop to e3 here what's the move
their queen c6 may hmm I don't know but
this runs into Bishop b5 Bishop e3 just
looks like the most obvious move yes sir
but Bishop b5 maybe he intends to know
there's also Queen deform queen d4
Knight g4 it looks okay it's not bad but
I don't know if it is really great there
should be five there's Quincy seven I
think he is arguing that um that Bishop
move doesn't help me that much hmm i
would like to play 24 but 94 is kind of
is kind of annoying that's not bad so
bad
you can also argue that Knight takes e4
I mean if I go look to see 194 there's
not be five and I'm probably just
winning maybe this is a good move right
where's the Queen going took me ages to
to come up with it but I think it's
pretty strong right naughty for nye p5
should win the house now that looks good
right that if one happy 525 I'll take
the five play 9700 twins maybe even more
than the exchange did we win they
exchange for sure but maybe more yeah
this I didn't have on the radar at all
yeah well mighty mighty III of course
but what about hmm
a TC for Quincy for know that Bishop g4
maybe I mean I would have some
substantial compensation here in almost
any case but difficult to tell what's
the best home épisode de phones well
night before the squeegee for me I'm
playing this in a very complicated way I
probably should have played it and more
in a simpler way but okay it's quite
crazy both sides having spent around two
minutes round three minutes in 94 their
screen g-form and nine takes be to queen
bee three is trapping the noid
and now I'm threatening things like like
taking on f6 and 24 for example probably
also some kind of Bishop takes e4 like
Bishop c4 Quincy for Bishop f6 takes
check on g-form King in the in the
corner Gwinnett form lines like that
that will probably win because he has no
defense of peas anymore this is
interesting okay okay I'll take him
cannot calculate this now take screen
takes is fantastic Queen takes before I
guess we should be 590 form i still have
PG form
I guess yeah well he has to not sure
about this this thing is it takes before
I don't see Wow he plays that I thought
that was entirely unplayable Queen takes
why is that move let's see 94 what no
I've got 55 then
95 was also interesting okay so cannot
take high morals now I can just take
this play it play it simple for for once
it takes that was a check so that was
quite irritating Queen g6 may be
attacking g2 and Bishop age 3 in the in
the mix no stop doing this there should
be six as possibly on going to avoid
that yeah this is what I said but I
didn't really react to it should age
three
Wow not sure if that was a good solution
really not I'm blundering a pawn here
from that fantastic position check check
check draw unhurt they offer to me draw
here because I jack I'm just clicker I'm
not quicker well not if I'm a lot
quicker always a lot quicker than him
DRA are hurt I cannot do more than that
check not going outside the gates
archived after I've been so utterly
winning earlier huh what what happened
to him yeah I should I should just I
should just don't probably improve here
okay they're opening the opening phases
is very tough
yeah i just said hard game yeah and it
was it was it was quite a quite a tough
game yeah they had an excellent position
out of the opening here I think yeah it
took me ages to find Luke c1 which is
just the strongest move Bishop t4 is an
interesting choice I can also take first
and then go Bishop g4 which is maybe
easier and that's given as excellent by
the engine gives you five Teague's give
stuff like this with a fantastic
position for white yeah that really
looks great ok this happened and we and
no he he went with this which I fat
which I didn't have on the radiator I
felt just that why should win here but
it's not that easy it's not that easy
yeah then the computer just wants to
Castle here now you know what I didn't
see I mean I thought about canceling but
I felt that this should be six would be
okay for him as b2 is also hanging but I
have cream should be five this is saving
this is saving the pawn and here why
this is just a pawn up for no
compensation there are okay this is what
I should do yeah yeah I have to create
you six it's already it's pretty awful
this is I think not such a bad idea
actually I mean to give up the porn and
try to activate now here I should go F
for according to end to go ng
with equal with equal plane when equal
players school rights because it's it's
a it's own it's a very sharp position
but it's kind of believable that it
should be okay for why they've got some
activity through going to see if I were
going to G father the only the king is
open yeah after this I'm probably
struggling but here we had no time it
was a click fest already check yahoo g3
was keeping the pawn check David was
just clicking him I tried to offer him a
draw him I know that I'm quicker with
three moves at the end we have played a
number of games and I felt the draw is
kind of kind of reasonably after I had a
winning position of much better position
and then he got got into this but he
cannot cannot convert it with with this
time oh is this his speed of play yeah
tough game tough game okay i hope you
enjoyed it and give me some feedback on
the technical side of things I will
definitely I will record Blitz videos
for 4 from Monday the 29th of course but
I would like to have some information
about this video how it felt for you in
terms of sound and everything so
probably the videos they will not be
released at the usual time a little bit
later but I want to know if this is a
good setup or not okay well thanks for
watching